all right quan alexander gets traded for
a linebacker yeah alonso what what do
you think the reasoning is for the 49ers
making that move i think most likely
they realized he wasn't going to be on
their roster last next year that that
time had come and gone and i think the
second thing is you know they gotta they
gotta pay these two linebackers that are
there i mean fred warner
he's he's gonna get he's gonna demand to
be paid like one of the highest middle
linebackers in football and then the guy
that got dre greenlaw next to him he's a
damn good football player too so i'm
sure they looked at that a little bit
and go wait we got to start figuring out
how we're going to sign them long term
they're a huge part of their defense
they really are i mean that's their
bobby wagner kj wright combination there
like in that seattle scheme so they need
those guys and you know fred warner
if you watch you know any games recently
he's he's all over the place i mean he's
everywhere sideline to sideline can
cover anybody uh he's a phenomenal
football player
yeah and uh look they're not throwing in
the towel here they're just making plans
for next season and quan alexander a guy
that they signed coming off of a torn
acl you know they got a history of doing
that that was mainly a trent bulky thing
but
signing these guys bringing these guys
in and hoping that the rehab works and
sometimes it does and sometimes it
doesn't and sometimes other guys end up
being better before you get a chance to
do what you can do but alexander goes
back to the nfc south he'll be with the
saints he won't be able to play on
sunday night against the buccaneers his
original team because of the covet 19
protocols and that's why i'm still
surprised to see trades happening
because you're not getting these guys
for week nine due to the waiting period
and isn't it weird that they have like
you're it's not like you're coming in
off the street you've been tested every
day every day every day
and then you get sent to a new team
where you continue to be tested every
day but i guess the act of traveling is
enough right that they there's a risk
that when you're traveling outside of
the nfl approved
procedures maybe you catch it so they
want to wait and see and make sure you
didn't catch it while you're making your
trip from your old team to your new team
so today is the final day for the
the trade uh period it closes at 4 p.m
eastern i don't know
actually we're gonna see i thought yeah
but again a little more than this really
but but again and the thought last year
or last week excuse me very prevalent if
you're going to do a deal you got to do
it now because then you you know there's
not many games left you're losing the
opportunity to get the guy ready to play
in week nine and you're doing it to
enhance your team and the sooner that
guy's playing for you the sooner he's up
to speed the sooner he's ready to go you
delay the whole process by a week
because of this covenant yeah you're
right you're right about oh just to say
you're right about that but you still
get them and i think the teams that are
making these moves just just to say this
mike it is about long term it's like
okay yeah we don't you know they're
thinking like we're a super bowl team or
we're a deep in the playoffs team and
it's that i think big picture in mind
too and yeah they might not get them
right now but i think it's more about
december january and and improving their
team that way
well right but the sooner he's on the
field no i know
the sooner he's taking reps the sooner
he gets to his ceiling and he can help
you get to the playoffs and then help
you win when you get there and and look
you've got one more data point i think
that's one of the reasons why teams
waited maybe the chargers hold on to
desmond king if they win on sunday even
though he was disgruntled and he wasn't
playing hey he's insurance in the event
somebody gets injured now maybe you
don't need that insurance policy if you
know that you can't hold a 17-point lead
because you've had three of them yeah
you've blown all of them
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports